[Music]
it was a mixup this is true there was a
real mix-up on MSNBC yesterday MSNBC was
teasing a story an upcoming story about
French President Nicolas Sarkozy they
accidentally put up the wrong subtitle
when they were doing the story and as I
said this is absolutely real and it went
out over the air take a look
neck-and-neck new battleground polling
showing that it's going to be a
nail-biter of a race angry voters give
French presidents
yeah that's a mistake I just I was lucky
that actually saw that at home as
watching the usual I said is it that
terrible Andy it's awful it is I mean
the guy just lost an election but he
still deserves some kinda respect don't
you think
yeah it doesn't matter if you lose an
election you should be able to still
represent it your words accurately
that's what should happen absolutely I
mean and I think that there should be
somebody fired because of it because
that kind of mistake shouldn't happen
now someone should lose their job or
that someone should be held accountable
when there's no accountability in news
that's where people get in trouble there
has to be some sort of integrity in the
TV business I'm with you why even watch
television if people are making mistakes
on this kind of grand scale it's
horrible I for one am appalled and think
someone should lose their job
isn't that right lebombo you're
absolutely right
ladies and gentle Abama worked for six
hours today on that performance
did you see him in the hallway working
on his line working on his line